kaum jemand scheint die dimension zu
erfassen die hinter bisher
verschlossenen türen bei tesla
stattfindet oder eben nicht also wird
dort in den nächsten tagen oder wenigen
wochen tatsächlich bahnbrechendes
passieren oder würde es einfach nur ein
fiasko einiges spricht dafür dass die
welt ende 2021 in sachen künstlicher
intelligenz eine andere ist und tesla
wirklich für eine revolution sorgen wird
und zwar mit dem schnellsten
supercomputer der welt doclx um science
im future bis dreimal pro woche
spannendes heinz videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen in den letzten tagen wurde er
plötzlich alles klar und die
erkenntnisse der letzten jahre monate
wochen und tage begannen sich zu
verknüpfen wir werden dieses jahr einen
riesigen schritt in der entwicklung der
künstlichen intelligenz machen tesla
wird mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit mit
sehr hoher wahrscheinlichkeit nicht nur
das problem des autonomen fahrens lösen
sondern auch generell was die
entwicklung von künstlicher intelligenz
angeht einen absoluten bahnbrechenden
meilenstein erreichen und den
entscheidenden hinweis darauf habe ich
in meinem tesla gefunden denn etwas ist
absolut kurios und mysteriös seit januar
gibt es keine größeren updates mehr für
die tester software
die entwicklung wurde praktisch
eingestellt bisher konnte man die uhr
danach stellen alle vier wochen gab es
ein größeres update der testsoftware mit
neuen features und deutlichen
verbesserungen alle vier wochen
nachvollziehen lässt sich das über die
versionsnummer der jahreszahl 2020 gab
es eine version 4.8 12 16 20 24 und so
weiter und so fort die zahl bezog sich
immer auf die kalenderwoche wie ein
uhrwerk kamen die updates alle vier
wochen doch dieses uhrwerk steht dieses
jahr seit ende januar seitdem gibt es
nur minimale verbesserung der software
die letzte version die sich meinen wagen
zog war die version 20 21 4 15
sprich seit januar also der vierten
kalenderwoche wird die software nicht
mehr weiterentwickelt der einzige
logische schluss das entwicklungsteam
wurde abgezogen und
es wird jetzt mit aller kraft an der
vollversion für wirkliches autonomes
fahren gearbeitet spricht die software
wird sehr bald erscheinen und es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass die letzte beta
version mit der versionsnummer 9.0 im
mai also jetzt erscheinen wird bei the
way darauf gekommen bin ich weil ich
gerade intensiv zu tesla recherchiere
für mein neues buch tesla oder wyhlen
maske die elektromobilität
revolutioniert dahin gibt es noch mehr
verblüffende erkenntnisse über die
elektro auto energie und jetzt auch ki
firma wer es als erstes in der hand
halten möchte sollte es jetzt
vorbestellen gibt es überall wo es gute
bücher gibt also in jeder buchhandlung
oder hier und da unter mich mit einem
klick jetzt gibt es zwei wichtige punkte
die extremen dagegen sprechen nicht dass
die software erscheint das passiert auf
jeden fall sondern dass sie überhaupt
auf öffentlichen straßen eingesetzt
werden kann respektive überhaupt
vollständig autonom agieren kann
punkt eins ist leicht zu lösen so lange
die voreiligen version kurz ssd
übersetzt volles selbst fahren nicht
erlaubt wird solange ist einfach die
überwachung durch die fahrenden
erforderlich sprich die software ist
tatsächlich in der lage vollständig
autonom zu fahren allerdings lässt sie
sich nicht aktivieren wie bisher auch
erforderlich müssen die hände auf dem
lenkrad liegen und leicht daran ziehen
ansonsten schaltet sich die software ab
punkt zwei ist da die größte
herausforderung beziehungsweise frage
wird die software überhaupt dazu in der
lage seien autonom zu fahren nichts wird
in den letzten monaten heftiger
diskutiert und die videos die man
überall auf youtube bewundern kann
die lassen beide möglichkeiten zu zum
einen werden hier beeindruckende
reaktionen der software demonstriert
lange strecken werden vollkommen
problemlos ohne menschliche eingriffe
zurückgelegt zum andern macht sie noch
große fehler die ein mensch nie machen
würde und wiederum schildern beta tester
eine wirklich unglaubliche erfahrung mit
ihren fahrzeugen die wegstrecken nahezu
menschlich zurücklegen und das ist genau
der punkt und daran werden sich am ende
die geister scheiden was ist überhaupt
volles autonomes fahren denn am ende
machen auch menschen fehler und sind
nicht in der lage voll autonom zu fahren
ich bin mal bei schlechter sicht und
regen aus kübeln fast auf bahngleise ein
gebot
wird das die tester software anders
machen was ist also volles autonomes
fahren wahrscheinlich muss man sich am
ende darauf einigen dass wenn eine
software das statistisch besser als
menschen macht das als voll autonomes
fahren gewertet wird und vielleicht gibt
es verkehrssituationen die wirklich
erstmal sehr sehr schwierig für eine
künstliche intelligenz sind deswegen
ehrlich gesagt denke ich dass es
deswegen mindestens noch bis zum ende
des jahres wenn nicht bis anfang
nächsten jahres dauern wird bis wirklich
volles autonomes fahren erlangt wird es
gibt so viele besondere situation für
die wird wahrscheinlich noch etwas
trainieren müssen allerdings und da
verstehen viele einfach nicht das
prinzip von künstlicher intelligenz ist
sie einmal trainiert dann ist sie immer
besser als der mensch teilweise ist sie
dann in der lage probleme zu lösen
zu deren lösung wir gar nicht in der
lage wären die software der
google-tochter die meint hat das mit
alpha go und alpha fold demonstriert
alpha go ist der beste golfspieler der
welt und alpha volk kann proteine falten
in einer perfektion und mit einer
erfolgsquote die vorher unmöglich
erschien und das ist weitaus
komplizierter als straßenverkehr aber
warum ist künstliche intelligenz in
einzelnen disziplinen den menschen so
überlegen wieso kann ki so überragendes
leisten was so mind blowing ist die
erklärung ist gottseidank ziemlich
einfach und lässt vermuten warum tesla
hier etwas absolut bahnbrechendes
präsentieren wird das prinzip von
künstlicher intelligenz ist erst einmal
das gleiche wie im gehirn es werden
nicht befehle wie zum beispiel wenn dann
verarbeitet beim normalen prozessor wird
nach eingabe einer zahl oder eines
buchstabens mit der tastatur dieser oder
diese auf dem monitor angezeigt dass es
sehr effizient und simpel und logisch
die künstliche intelligenz müsste das
erst lernen es wäre viel komplexer und
sie müsste erst einmal trainiert werden
dann aber kann sie viel mehr sie könnte
erkennen wenn die finger die tasten
nicht exakt treffen oder daneben liegen
und und zum teil wird das ja auch
bereits schon angewendet aber noch auf
einem sehr einfachen niveau und es
funktioniert noch nicht wirklich perfekt
autokorrektur kann einen schon mal in
den wahnsinn treiben eine künstliche
intelligenz nimmt mit sensoren also
erstmal das geschehene war bei tesla
sind es acht kameras die den verkehr
ringsum wahrnehmen das radar das auch in
den fahrzeugen verbaut ist
nicht mehr verwendet weil es
offensichtlich widersprüchliche
informationen geben kann zwischen radar
und kameras und dann ist die ki einfach
überfordert und weiß nicht wem sie
glauben soll also radar ist abgeschaltet
weil sie ihren mast mit der visuellen
erkennung viel mehr geleistet werden
kann dann kommt das lernen was sehe ich
da und das geht weit darüber hinaus
lediglich das objekt zu erkennen zu
verstehen denn kann eigenschaften
erkennen die wir gar nicht wahrnimmt wie
unterscheidet man eine lok von einem lkw
zb ki hat auch eine ganz einfache lösung
gefunden an den gleisen auf denen eine
lok fährt und das hat sie lediglich
damit gelernt dass er immer wieder
gesagt wurde das ist eine lok das ist
ein lkw das ist eine lok das ist ein lkw
und so weiter und so kann die kriterien
zur unterscheidung entwickeln die für
uns nicht unbedingt erkennbar sind die
ki von tesla für das autonome fahren hat
zum beispiel kriterien entwickelt für
fahrzeuge die vielleicht die spur
wechseln sie kann vorhersagen ob das
passiert oder eben nicht und das besser
als wir menschen das liegt daran dass
die ki viel mehr daten zur verfügung hat
als wir menschen jeweils haben werden
big data ihr erfahrungsschatz ist so
viel größer als der von jedem menschen
so viele auch gefahren sein sollte die
ki wird immer mehr wissen und sie hat es
sich gemerkt und zwar nicht als riesige
datenbank sondern als regel
sie hat sich selbst so programmiert dass
sie weiß was als nächstes mit welcher
wahrscheinlichkeit passieren wird und
passt die fahrweise dementsprechend an
und jede sekunde überprüft das um
korrigiert wiederum ihr verhalten und
die fsd version haben bisher
beeindruckendes gezeigt und sie werden
jedes mal besser aber wie kann das sein
und wie kann ein so kleiner computer in
einem test hat das leisten
das maß der dinge ist hier die leistung
in teraflops also wie viele fließkomma
berechnungen ein computer pro sekunde
macht und da gehören die tester rechner
in den fahrzeugen zum schnellsten auf
dem markt sie schaffen unglaubliche 144
millionen berechnungen pro sekunde das
sind 144 teraflops die konkurrenz kommt
hier nicht annähernd auf diese werte und
das zeigt wohl hier bei der konkurrenz
die lücken sind esther hat von
vornherein so groß oder in diesem fall
schnell gedacht im sinne von
prozessorleistung wie es für das
autonome fahren wirklich
nötig zu sein scheint und die
prozessoren in diesen rechnern sind auf
ki optimiert auf der platine stecken
zwei state of the art car i prozessoren
die dafür speziell entworfen worden
allerdings und das ist das zweite
nadelöhr diese rechner sind mit ihrer
leistung nicht annähernd dafür geeignet
die ki zu trainieren das gelernte kann
nach dem training darauf problemlos
ausgeführt werden aber lernen können
diese computer nicht dafür braucht es
einen besonderen computer und jetzt wird
die dimension deutlich in der tesla das
autonome fahren angeht und das ist
tatsächlich mit nichts zu vergleichen es
geht um giorgio ist der computer auf dem
die ki trainiert die bezeichnung kommt
aus dem japanischen und bedeutet soviel
wie ort des weges also der platz wo man
den weg trainiert wie zum beispiel judo
der wortteil bedeutet weg und jo platz
oder ort in japan sind das zum beispiel
die orte an denen youtube oder aikido
trainiert wird joe wird im moment bei
tesla in betrieb genommen oder läuft
schon die schnelligkeit die entwicklung
und die fortschritte der fsd software
fahrer jetzt bei der version neun
sprechen dafür dass er schon läuft
beziehungsweise server schrank für
server schrank aufgebaut und in betrieb
genommen wird ist er fertig aufgebaut
ist tot der schnellste supercomputer der
welt ihnen maske hat eine leistung von
einem extra flop angekündigt der
momentan schnellste computer der welt
fugato schafft mit 400 15,5 peter fox
nicht ganz die hälfte und er wird aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach mit genau den
motherboards aus den tesla pkw oder
nachfolgern arbeiten denn sie haben die
optimalen daten für einen solchen
supercomputer mit 144 teraflops leistung
benötigt man lediglich 7.000 platinen
die in knapp 40 serverschränke passen
würden bei fugato sind es 400
serverschränke da die rechner in pkw mit
batterien laufen sind sie auf extrem
sparsamen stromverbrauch ausgelegt sie
haben einen strombedarf von 100 watt bei
7.000 bord sind das 700 kilowatt und ein
bisschen mehr für die peripherie fugato
benötigt 28.300 34 kilowatt es wird auch
der sparsamste supercomputer der welt
mit abstand er wird dann in der lage
sein oder ist es schon oder ist es in
teilen schon die ki für autonomes fahren
extrem schnell zu optimieren
dabei legt er sich alle daten und video
aufnahmen zu einer bestimmten
verkehrssituationen aus den tesla
fahrzeugen hoch deren inhaber und
inhaberinnen dem zugestimmt haben damit
trainiert die ki dann und spielt das
ergebnis des trainings dann auf die
fahrzeuge als update zurück inzwischen
beherrscht die software bereits die
allermeisten situation mit deutsch kann
die software jetzt in wenigen wochen so
optimiert werden dass sie komplett
autonom fahren kann und jedes mal wenn
dann noch irgendwo auf der welt eine
situation auftaucht in der die software
nicht weiter weiß lädt sich toto
weltweit die daten hoch und einen tag
später können die tester fahrzeuge diese
situation meistern
die idee dass alle teslas dann als robo
taxis verwendet werden können ist
technisch dann nur noch ein katzensprung
die größte hürde sind dann die
gesetzgeber das alles ist ein riesiger
meilenstein die software für autonomes
fahren ist demnach in wenigen wochen
komplett fertig und ende juli will ihren
mast die fähigkeiten von testern bereich
künstliche intelligenz vorstellen und
tesla wird damit zum weltweit führenden
anbieter von künstlicher intelligenz
denn wenn die entwicklung der fst
software abgeschlossen ist will er die
fähigkeiten von togo kommerziell
anbieten und andere firmen können dann
seine fähigkeiten nutzen
es ist der beginn einer neuen ära und
auch im bereich künstliche intelligenz
hätte tesla dann maßstäbe gesetzt
tesla oder wie ihnen maske die
elektromobilität revolutioniert jetzt
bestellen und zu den ersten gehören die
dieses buch mit allen
hintergrundinformationen zu tesla in den
händen halten das buch gibt es in jeder
guten buchhandlung auch zum vorbestellen
oder hier einfach draufklicken und ab
geht die post sobald das buch erschienen
ist ich bin sehr auf die reaktion
gespannt bis dann bleibt dran